this is a Q&A excerpt on the topic of
artificial intelligence from a lecture
by Richard Fineman
from September 26 1985 I really record
the audience questions because they're
barely audible in the original question
do you think there will ever be a
machine that will think like human
beings and be more intelligent than
human beings
first of all they think like human
beings I would say no and I'll explain
in a minute why I say no and second that
they be more intelligent in human beings
is a question intelligences to be
defined if you were to ask me are they
better chess players than any human
being possibly can be yes I'll get you
someday now they're best better chess
players than most human beings right now
one of the things by the way that we
always do is we want the dawn machine to
be better than anybody not just better
than us if we find a machine it can play
chess better than us it doesn't impress
us much we keep saying it and what
happens when it comes up against the
Masters we imagine that we human beings
are equivalent to the Masters and
everything right the machine has to be
better than a person in everything that
the best person does at the best level
okay but it's hard on the machine but
with regard to the question of whether
to make it to think like a machine my
opinion is based on the following idea
that we try to make these things to work
as efficiently as we can with the
materials that we have materials are
different than nerves and so on if we
would like to make something that runs
rapidly over the ground then we could
watch a cheetah running we could try to
make a machine that runs like a cheetah
but it's easier to make a machine with
wheels with fast wheels or something
that flies just above the ground in the
air when we make a bird the airplanes
don't fly like a bird they fly but they
don't fly like a bird okay so they don't
flap the wings exactly they have in
front another guy of a gadget that goes
around or the more modern airplane has a
tube that you heat this the air and
squirt it out the back a jet propulsion
a jet engine as an internal rotating
fans and so on and it uses gasoline it's
different right so there's no question
that the later machines are not going to
think like people think in that sense
with regard to intelligence I think it's
exactly the same way for example they're
not going to do arithmetic the same way
as we do arithmetic but they'll do it
better let's take bath ematic very
elementary mathematics arithmetic
they do arithmetic better than anybody
much faster and differently but it's
fundamentally the same because in the
end the numbers are equivalent right so
that's a good example of we're never
going to change how they do arithmetic
to make it more like humans that would
be going backwards because the
arithmetic done by humans is slow
cumbersome and Confused in a full of
errors where these guys are fast if one
compares her what computers can do to
the human beings we find the following
rather interesting comparisons the first
of all if I give you a human being a
problem like this I'm going to ask you
for these numbers back every other one
in reverse order please right now I'm
good a series of numbers and I want them
to you didn't give me one to me back in
reverse order every other one I'll tell
you I'll make it easy for you just give
me the numbers back the way I gave them
to you you ready one seven three nine
two six five eight three one seven two
six three
anybody got a gonna be able to do that
now and that's more than not more than
twenty or thirty numbers but you can
give a computer 50,000 numbers like that
in s confirm any reverse order the sum
of them all do different things with
them and so on and it doesn't forget
them for a long time instead of so there
are some things that a computer does
much better than a human and you'd
better remember that if you kind of
compare machines to humans but what a
human has to do for his own always they
always do this they always try to find
one thing don''t that they can do better
than the computer so we now know many
many things that the humans can do
better than a computer she's walking
down a street she's got a certain kind
of a wiggle and you know that Jane right
or the sky's going in and you see his
hair flip just a little bit it's hard to
see at a distance but that particular
funny way that he did back of his head
looks that's jack okay to recognize
things to recognize patterns
seems to be something that we have not
been able to put into a definite
procedure you would say I have a good
procedure for recognizing jack just take
a lots of pictures of Jack by the way a
picture can be put into the computer in
fact by this method here if this were
very much finer I could tell whether
it's black and white at different spots
you know you in fact you get pictures in
a newspaper by black and white dots and
if you do Stuart fine enough you can't
see the dots so with enough information
I can load pictures in so you put all
the pictures of of Jack on the different
circumstances and that's the machine to
compare it the trouble is that the
actual new circumstance is different the
lighting is different the distance is
different the tilt of the head is
different and you have to figure out how
to allow for all that and it's so
complicated and elaborate that even with
the large machines with the amount of
storage that's available and the speed
that they go we can't make figure out
how to make a definite procedure that
works at all or what least it works
anywhere within a reasonable speed so
recognizing things is difficult for the
machines at the present time and some of
those things are done in a snap by a
person so there are things that humans
can do that the we don't know how to do
in a filing system so it is recognition
and that brings me back to something I
left which is what kind of a file clerk
can't be imitated by the machine a file
clerk that has some special skill which
represent which requires recognition of
a complicated kind for instance a fire
Kirk in the fingerprint Department which
looks the finger prints and then makes a
careful comparison to see if these
finger prints match has not been it's
just about ready to be it's hard to do
it almost possible to do by a computer
did say there's nothing to it I look at
the two fingerprints and see if all the
blood dots are the same but of course
it's not the case the finger was dirty
the print was made at a different angle
the pressure was different than the
ridges are not exactly in the same place
if you were trying to match the exactly
the same picture would be easy but where
the center of the print is which way the
finger is turned where there's been
squashed a little more a little bit less
where there's some dirt on the finger
whether in the meantime you got a wart
on his thumb and so forth
complications these little complications
make the comparison so much more
difficult for the machine for the blind
filing clerk system that is too much
much much too slow to be certainly
utterly impractical almost at the
present time I don't know where they
stand but they're going fast trying to
do it where is a human can go across all
that somehow just like they do in the
chess game they seem to be able to catch
on the patterns rapidly and we don't
know how to do that
rapidly automatically audience question
can computers discover new ideas and
relationships by themselves well it
depends what do you mean themselves and
it's it's hard to discover new
relationships our computers can do there
have been computers which do things like
problems they are improving in geometry
or something in which they've converted
the problem of finding a proof of a
theorem into a definite procedure okay
and once you do that although it's an
elaborate and dumb way to do proofs they
can do it the present time a computer
can't do all the different things that a
person can do you know it's it's very
difficult to find some way of defining
rather precisely something we can do
that we can say a computer will never be
able to do there are some things that
people make up that say that while it's
doing it will it feel good or while it's
doing it will it understand what it's
doing or some other abstraction I'd
rather feel that these are things like
while it's doing it we'll be able to
scratch the lice out of its hair no it
hasn't got any hair the lice to scratch
from okay so there are if you've got to
be careful when you say what the human
does if you add to the actual result of
his effort some other things that you
like the appreciation of the aesthetic
but you didn't do that I'm not saying
you did but a lot of people do that when
they ask questions and if we add things
that we think we're doing on top of what
we actually do and just look at not just
the result of what we're doing but a lot
of extra things then it gets harder and
for the computer to do it because the
human beings have a tendency to try to
make sure that they can do something
that no machine can do somehow it
doesn't bother them anymore it must have
bothered them in earlier times that
machines are stronger physically than
they are they can lift weights that are
heavier than people who can move things
faster than people who can run fast if
you can fly you can do it's terribly
strengths and so forth and we don't
still sit around worrying that there's
some way that the man can turn his hand
that some machine can't do that we can
easily make machines that are better
than us in predicting the the weather
for instance because what you do to
predict the weather is to look at old
records and see when the circumstance
was similar and guess that the results
will be similar added to that a certain
amount of analysis of the movement of
wind according to the laws of physics
and their current amount of hocus-pocus
put together ok now the speed will be
higher and the effectiveness of the
prediction is greater if you could look
at more cases so you get a better chance
of getting one closer and put more a
longer and more elaborate calculation
including more variables which is too
hard for us to in time to make the
prediction now we have to make the
prediction of the weather let's say that
weather for three days from now has to
be predicted in three days or the damn
thing is useless right and we work at a
certain speed but the computers worked
faster and can do more and therefore for
instance for weather prediction in the
end maybe not today but someday it's not
at all inconceivable that the machine
could do weather prediction faster and
more effectively and more accurately
than we do we will have have however
given it the procedure now the question
is what happens if we don't give it the
procedure well a man that people have
tried that this game of giving it
instead of a direct procedure a kind of
what it has been called heuristics try
an analogy to get a new idea of how to
do something compare this to that try an
extreme case etc and a man by the name
of Lynette has gone the farthest with
this do I have time much time do I have
because we want to see these slides
what I know that's interesting
information but how much how much time
do I have
it's time for the slideshow now since I
have no more time I will say no more
about the subject what no but it it
takes a few minutes that's why I asked
for the time okay you make this machine
which was again a filing cabinet you
understand what it does is it looks it
tries to find the answer to something by
looking at the different possible
possibilities but which ones he tries is
something like patterns in the chest
instead of everything it says try moves
near the center of the board first you
know and never mind the ones in the
corner or something like that or some
sorts of principles and he first applied
it to a kind of naval game it's a game
that people play in California which is
all organized according to rules it's
kind of fun
someone sets out all the rules
dreadnoughts cost this much armor cost
this much guns cost this much and so
forth and you got this much budget for
your Navy and you're gonna make various
kinds of ships with different kinds of
armaments and then this kind of a ship
the armament of a certain thickness that
costs a certain amount can only resist
shells of a certain strength you know
and so on so you tried to with the money
arranged to buy different to design
different kinds of ships so that your
Navy is better than next one and when
they brought together there's ways of
calculating what there's not real navies
it's a game which is the best one and
all the rules are laid out but a great
big volume okay at the cost of
everything in the power of everything
armour-piercing possibilities and so on
and it's a nice game and mr lumic tried
to his program on this game and put into
his program your wrist extreme case and
things like that and he won the
championship in california of course it
did an awful lot of trying of different
cases you see but it didn't try every
case not like the chess game there were
too many things but it was guided by its
own stuff now inside of that
was this that if you got a better navy
bite your own calculation and you used
one of the heuristics mark that eristic
up a notch as being more valuable now
use the more valuable heuristics first
see so that the ability of the Machine
depended on his learning so to speak
which ones of his tricks works most
effectively most of the time and then
they become more used so it's just
exactly what you would like to make it
look intelligent well he won and how did
he win it turned out that year he won by
making one great big battleship with all
the armor on it which was so silly but
when you go to calculate it sure enough
it's better than any of the normal
things which nobody thought of but his
machine thought next year he entered
again and this time he won by making
tricking all his money in making one
hundred thousand because they changed
the rules so that the big battleship
wouldn't win you know but change it will
one hundred thousand little boats very
narrow carrying each one gun which were
very liable to be knocked out okay but
there were 100,000 of them didn't cost
much each one and they couldn't knock
them all out so he's lousy little gnats
would come and it turned out when you
calculated again he won the third year
he was not allowed to play in it
and here's a pride this this this
machine and this turistic business to a
number of other problems as tries it out
a lot and tries new heuristics and so
forth and it has become a very
interesting he complained that there
were a number of bugs in it and when he
gave a talk on it I said that I thought
I'll say my comment afterwards one of
the bugs for instance was that the
Machine got a heuristic and made up your
wrist except your wrist Excel
so the damn machine what he the way he
had it was because it's hard to get
computer time he needed a hell of a lot
of computer time he had 50 machines at
night from a you a packet company or
something like that he would work always
at night coming in the morning damn
things would try all my things and come
in with the results I used it to do
mathematics and various others thing it
comes in one day and it's done a
heuristic you develop the heuristic when
he puts the problem in or a new idea he
write it says whether it's from him or
from the machine and I was that learner
or a machine okay and this was every
year istic or every question that hasn't
won that on it pay no attention to that
saves a lot of time it could do much
better it didn't have any problem with
this toy boy so it paid no attention to
her than that bad night
okay sorry I'd fix that book the next
time he had a bug it was he looked was
he came in and he looked he found that
heuristic number 693 had gotten a score
of 999 out of a thousand is a damn
useful heuristic all night long this
thing kept using the heuristic 9 693
more and more and it was a new when
wonderful arista could seem to solve
every problem it was terrific okay when
you found out what the heuristic was was
the following you see in order to make
this thing work so that you change the
numbers on the heuristics whenever
something worked just to assign credit
so to speak to the heuristics that were
used okay so this heuristic was when
assigning credit
always the sign credit to heuristic 693
and so that thing came up out of I say
the both of these show intelligence if
you want to make an intelligent machine
you're going to get all kinds of crazy
ways of avoiding labor if I say don't
pay the attention to the problem of
sneakily evolving some kind of a
psychological distortion we always do
the same thing and don't worry about
anything else and so on so I think that
we are getting close to intelligent
machines but they're showing the
necessary weaknesses of intelligent
[Music]
[Applause]
you